thank you for being on the programme
well you asked a question
to the prime minister since then we've
had yet more resignations a sacking
we've had members of the cabinet going
into number 10 demanding that the prime
minister resign
he hasn't it is like he is digging in
what do you think the answer to your
question is do you think there are any
circumstances where the prime minister
might resign
well i i don't know and that's why i
asked the prime minister i didn't get a
very good answer and can i just say
sophie i really do sympathize with james
duddridge who is a fantastic colleague
and to be sent out by number 10
to give kamiko ali a run for his uh
money is is pretty poor and defending
the the indefensible the game is up and
i didn't take any joy in asking that
question uh today but it needed to be uh
to be asked and that crack in the dam we
saw last night when uh sajid and rushi
handed their notice has now become a
huge hole
in the dam with a succession of very
talented ministers uh deciding that
enough is enough today and the prime
minister really needs to acknowledge
that not trying to tough it out because
frankly it's now we're now in the end
game and he needs to acknowledge that he
needs to resign with the dignity on his
own uh terms and we can all say thank
you very much and then get on with the
job of electing a new leader and a new
prime minister which is what we need to
do urgently
you mentioned the interview that we just
heard with james duddridge he obviously
has a different view to you he thinks
that actually they can appoint new
ministers there's plenty of people who
are ready to serve there'll be a new
economic strategy next week and tax cuts
what's the problem
i don't believe james believes that i
mean it's just completely delusional a
large chunk of government and
particularly some really talented
ministers who had every expectation of
progressing and make it into the into
the cabinet i have said to boris what
i've been saying for many uh months now
and others around me
that his position is untenable and that
has come to a head at last thank god it
has come to a head because it was
completely distracting government from
getting on with the job of government
which is what we desperately need to get
back to uh
to to doing and so the game is up he
can't replace all those holes in the in
the government with other people because
frankly i think it really
struggled to find people who would now
want to serve in his government because
it's going to be a very short-term
appointment because frankly
he will have to go one way or the other
in the next few days i hope he does the
honourable thing and resigns on his own
terms but if not
then the 1922 committee executive will
change the rules next week and we'll
have another vote of confidence and as
bob seeley said earlier to you i've
absolutely no doubt that there will be a
not insignificant majority now saying
sorry prime minister but we don't have
the confidence in you anymore and if we
would have a very different result to
just a few weeks ago
it's interesting let's unpick that a bit
the 1922 committee who can call a
confidence
motion if enough letters go in but of
course they do need to change the rules
first to allow boris johnson to face a
second confidence motion after he
survived the first one how quickly do
you think this could all happen they're
obviously meeting to elect the new
officials on monday
well it could happen and it needs to
happen very quickly so what the 22
committee executives have decided and
they have a lot of power in this they
run the whole election uh procedures
they've and i think sensibly decided
that given we have elections annual
elections for the 22 executive uh which
is due to happen in the next few weeks
that it should be for the new committee
to decide if there's to be a rule change
because that's a big move and it's not
something i would like to see done uh
lightly so they've brought forward the
elections to monday so on on monday all
the nominations will be in
every conservative mp will have a vote
we will elect a new
uh executive committee of the 1922
and they will then decide whether they
want to change the rules and they'll do
so i think with a very
fresh and credible mandate having just
been elected to those positions so
people can't cry foul to say it was you
know they haven't got a mandate to well
they will have a brand new
mandate and if they decide there needs
to be a new vote of confidence which is
i think they will
then we can vote as early as monday
evening or or tuesday
and if that comes up with a vote of no
confidence of the prime minister's i
very strongly suspect it will then a
leadership challenge and a legit
competition can be put into place very
quickly and it all frankly needs to
happen before the summer recess in just
a few weeks time
before the final two contenders as it
works within a party structure can then
go out for the vote of the membership at
large in the in the country and i think
that process needs to be revisited
because it can take several months we
haven't got several months we need to
get on with this we need to have a new
leader a new prime minister getting
government back in the business of
running government
let's talk about that potential
leadership election shall we because it
did feel as if one of the reasons that
perhaps people
stayed their hands if you like at the
last vote was because there was no clear
challenger to the prime minister do you
think that has changed do you think
there are serious contenders now and is
there anyone that you would particularly
uh point to as having a good uh chance
at getting the top job
well there are serious uh contenders and
it isn't like you know back in the time
mrs thatcher that was michael hesden who
was uh circling uh with great ambitions
to be uh to be leader there are and
perhaps rishi sunak was a very strong uh
contender but recent events have rather
blotted his copy book i think very
unfairly actually but i could reel off
um a list of half a dozen or more names
of of good competent credible candidates
who uh could easily step up for the
leadership and could easily fit into the
shoes of a prime minister they'll be
very different prime minister
uh to um boris johnson frankly anybody's
gonna be a very different prime minister
to boris johnson but that's not to say
they can't do the the job at least as
well if not uh if not better
and just finally uh while we've got you
the big news this night tonight is the
sacking of michael j gove what is your
reaction to that
well i mean that's pretty serious i've
worked for mike with michael go for many
uh years and it's it's no great secret
that i'm not the biggest fan of michael
gove but michael gove has been
uh despite
some uh incidents in the past leadership
uh uh competitions he's been very much
at the side of uh of boris and boris has
been listening to him so for boris to
turn around and when i think it was
michael gave who went to number 10 with
the
the metaphorical
bottle of whiskey and the revolver uh
well clearly boris is down the whiskey
and turn the revolver and michael
michael gave who would have believed it